fire drills so if the alarm activates
please leave the building in an orderly
fashion near the nearest fire exit
please use either the fire exit through
the main doors of the hall while we exit
in the storeroom adjacent to the stage
at the fire assembly point is an island
in front of the main entrance to the
building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings do not return to
the building until given permission to
do so by Council staff and please note
the meeting will be live streamed
please switch off mobiles and turn them
to silent and please note that a toilet
and hand washing facilities available in
the fire air foyer area
um
members of the public and press you can
of course you're entitled to film or
take photographs during this meeting but
I must emphasize this should be done
without disruption to the meeting and
can only be done from a designated area
I don't believe we have anybody doing
that
can I please therefore ask anyone to
raise your hand clearly in the air if
you wish to take photographs or film
this evening
uh members there's a need to use
microphones during the meeting I invite
you to speak please speak clearly in the
microphones in front of you microphones
are needed for the hearing Loop and the
live stream members voting will be done
by a show of hands in line with the
Constitution they'll ask for a show of
hands and then against foreign against
recommendations and we'll also ask for a
show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from voting and now we have item
one with or gender item one apologies
for absence
[Music]
thank you
right
um
any non-members attending
as councilor Stanley
uh the next item is the minutes of the
meeting held on the 4th of July 2023
of anyone
any questions or issues about the
minutes
so those minutes are noted
thank you
uh and now item five to receive
Declarations of Interest
it's got their own number
uh item six is the 2022-23 financial
outrun draft financial statements which
are unaudited
uh to consider the report and the
interim director resources summarizing
and summarizing the overall financial
outturn position for the financial year
2022-23
which members have got for copies of the
report
and they'll hand over to Tim Willis the
director of resources
thank you Joe
um yes that's the chair highlights these
are the draft accounts for 2022-23 so
um sometimes they're called actuals or
out terms all means the same thing
and it's for the last year
um these were published on the council's
website three months ago
um and they are still subject to audits
of their draft accounts or unaudited
accounts
the audit will take place at some future
date but we don't know at the moment
um there are some variances by variances
we mean overspends or underspenders
um sometimes that's for income that's
more income than we expected or less
income than we expected as well as more
expenditure budget or less expenditure
than budget
um and sometimes they are referred to in
the report was adverse or favorable
variances the jargon around some of
these these financial statements is is
unavoidable sometimes
um favorable is when we're done better
than budget and adverse is when we've
done worse
um some of the variances are one-off or
due to Peculiar circumstances that some
are potentially recurring into 23-24 and
it's the sort of thing that I'm
particularly mindful of and something we
can learn from the from the final
accounts for 2223 if we're seeing
evidence that the same thing's happening
in the current year 23 24 we might want
to factor that into when we talk about
next year's budget which we will be soon
for 24 25 and Beyond
um some of the largest variances are
just draw members attention to there's
543 000 favorable variants on investment
income so we earned income on our cash
Holdings on our investments which were
543 000 more than we budgeted for in 22
23.
um there's also a council tax sharing
agreement in place with the county
um where we if we achieve certain levels
of council tax income because the county
get the bulk of the council tax income
they share a small element of that
benefit with districts including
rashford and that was 241 000 favorable
there's a housing benefit overspend of
186 000 we can't really do much about
that we pay our benefits and receive sub
received subsidy and like that's largely
controlled by government
um a couple of income for like fees and
charges income items
um planning fee income was 108 000
adverse so we we failed to achieve our
Target income budget for fees and
childhood for planning fee
fees and we overachieved on car parking
we generated a bit more income but we
also made savings on repairs and
maintenance in car parking and
consultancy to the tune of 258 000.
all of that is revenue the revenue
accounts that's the ongoing items
um there's also capital in relation to
the final accounts
um which is related to the capital
program which at the start of the year
was 5.6 million then we added in uh 800
000 of projects that didn't spend in the
previous year 2122 so they rolled over
we called it slipped the pro the
projects slipped so they didn't spend in
21-2 and they were agreed that they
would be carried over into 22-23 which
effectively added to the size of the
program so it was 6.4 million the
capital program
um the actual spend against the 6.4
million was only 3.8 million so we were
2.6 million under what we what we
planned to spend
um and uh we can look into the details
of that if necessary but I think most
people know why that would have been the
case we thought we'd start spending on
the ADP for example and we didn't
um but there are a few other more
smaller relevant items
I'm happy to try and answer any
questions people have or take them away
if there are questions of detail in
relation to the accounts and give back
to members afterwards thank you
Council Woodman
thank you chairman
um I think
looking at this report
it would be the Envy of many councils uh
in the United Kingdom when we're here on
a day-to-day basis the uh the pressures
and so I think it's really pleasing that
we can talk about uh
um underspins but uh my particular
question is please chairman is 1.5
um the fourth bullet point there
um to transfer a quarter of a million
pounds to create a new Reserve to enable
members too and I think that should be
two rather than row direct funds to
priorities not included in the base
budget
um is it possible for you please to
outline a little bit more detail because
this is after all an audit report and we
are supposed to be a little more
forensic than a quarter of a million
pounds just going into a reserve for
priorities we normally try and be a
little bit more specific especially in
an audit meeting thank you chairman uh
yeah thank you councilman um well we
have to ask the officers uh if there's a
sort of philosophy behind this because
obviously members would need to know
um
this is possible to do something with
this money yeah thank you
yes thank you chair um I think it's it's
probably true if we were thinking about
the budget for 24-5 and there was a
proposal to set aside 250 000 pounds for
something there'd be a lot of scrutiny
over whether or not that was appropriate
um and a priority over something else
because there were always demands on
when we set the budget
um which is a legal requirement what
this is is setting aside some of the
underspend to put into a reserve so in
that sense it's a it's not an active
spend we haven't spent the money we've
just put it into a pot and it's sitting
there to be used if it's needed and for
it to be used there would have to be
decisions made by Council or at least
executive in order to be able to use
that money so it wouldn't it would still
be it'll still be an element of
transparency about the spending of the
money and obviously the transparency on
um uh setting side Reserve is in the
published accounts in terms of the the
sort of justification for it
um in life that sorry there's a flyer
um in light of the um uh new
Administration
um
in a lot of cases around the council
around the country when there's a new
Administration there's there's a demand
for spending on specific items that may
need pump priming for example
um as well as stopping things because
it's a change in political control
um and at that time it's wise if there's
sufficient funding to set aside some
funding to allow for that rather than to
have to deal with it as and when it
arises or just say no
to everything
which was the philosophy behind setting
aside 250 000 of the reserve if we
hadn't done that we could have put it
into a reserve which
which would have been another ear mounts
Reserve which could have been something
like
a funding volatility Reserve in case we
guess we get our guess is wrong on
funding and we needed it or even in an
investment Reserve which we set aside
mainly to refund the capital program
um
if we've done that and then the new
Administration said we want to do
something that's really important and it
was approved at Council and it cost 250
000 it would have come from the same
would have come from the reserve where
we put the 250 000 anyway so in the
census is is just the the name that we
chose a discrete name for corporate
priorities
um for 250 000 that could have gone into
another ear March Reserve that it can be
generally available available for a
range of things
thank you
did that is that answer uh
chairman I think this is a classic
example where accountants and retired
Bankers perhaps have a different
perspective on uh the way we manage our
money
um but uh
um it seems a little strange to me that
when projects actually come up for
funding you take them out of an
earmarked reserves rather than
anticipate and earmarked reserves
accounts but you know I think that was a
fair answer from the section 151 officer
and I think we'll let it rest there but
thank you chairman
thank you councilman there was one thing
I'd like to ask about Tim worth
um in in discussion with you you
mentioned that the way the accounts are
presented in this form of report whom
Brentwood of the Brentwood council is
simpler and clearer
and we could actually benefit from those
that sort of changes is it possible to
obviously after this meeting to
circulate
um a document just gives an idea of what
that would entail and what it would look
like okay
thank you chair I would probably have
faced it that there are
um accounts presented by other councils
across the country that provide greater
Clarity over the outcome position than
the ones you have before you tonight and
that is a product of them being produced
in the way that they always have and I
didn't
um
take the opportunity to present these
differently after I arrived before these
were published and they they can be done
better I think there's some things in
there that I think are a little bit
confusing if you dig into the detail and
um one of the important things about
publishing accounts on our website as
well as for scrutiny in front of us
tonight is that there's enough Clarity
to the average reader to be able to
understand so they can comprehend and
then challenge if necessary and I feel
that we could do a bit better in that
regard
um as regards Brentwood I think and we
were having this conversation
um earlier chair there were there were
things because I'm section 151 both
councils
um there's two heads of Finance
um talk to each other they both report
to me we meet regularly and we compare
notes and there are often things that
Rochford do that Brentwood don't and
vice versa and we are already learning
from each other even before we Embark
upon a new route towards a shared
service and I think that shows the
benefit of a shared service I think
there are some lessons to learn from The
Way Brentwood presents its accounts and
indeed Carrie Cox head of Finance at
Rochford has said to me that very thing
maybe after we've we've come together I
can learn a few things about a better
way to present these accounts just as
there are examples where Sam at
Brentwood has said actually I don't know
why we do it like this we should do it
the same way the world should do it so I
think there's genuine benefits from
bringing two councils together just in
my not to say you don't look elsewhere
and wider as well but certainly there
are lessons that each can learn and
we're looking to exploit that as far as
possible
um yeah thanks very much too
looking at this
thank you
any other questions that's another thing
so really this is for us to note this
report so members as it noted
noted thank you
um and then we can move on to
item seven
um q1 internal audit progress report
and to consider the update report of the
audit and encounter fraud manager on the
work of the internal audit team and
progress made against the annual audio
plane for 20 23 24. thank you
and that's been presented by Mr Porter
thank you thank you chair
if I can ask members to turn to page 7.6
of the agenda pack
um so in terms of delivering progress
against audio playing we're making
fairly good progress against the plan
we've actually completed three audit
engagements
um for the period
um Fly tipping homeless reduction and an
audit of community safety partnership in
addition to those three audit reviews
we're also completed initial testing in
relation to their housing benefit
subsidy claim that's work we undertake
on behalf of external water so this is a
significant piece of work in terms of
audit resources it takes approximately
20 to 30 days to understand the piece of
work and we've now completed that piece
of work it's now with rest and Benz for
a sanity check as such and then it'll be
passed on to external audit for final
check-in to confirm our work is is
suitable in addition to that we have a
further to audit out a draft report
stage and and further to that we are
completely started working a further
forward reviews so we are making quite
good progress against the audit plan
today
there are however a couple of changes
we're looking to make to the audit plan
for 23 24. these are reviews in relation
to the asset development program and
also the Strategic Partnerships
um the reason why we're looking to
postpone those orders until next year is
in terms of strategic partnership it's a
bit too early on in terms of the Project
Life Cycle it's a two-year Project Life
Cycle and a member of service reviews
are still on ongoing so it's a bit early
for us to come in and look at it and and
look at the possible benefits from this
strategic partnership because they're as
I say there are a number of ongoing
service views and it's too early on to
identify what the benefits have been
achieved or not
um also in relation to the asset the
event program again this changes um in
terms of that program so again it's too
early on to look at that program until
those changes have been agreed so in
agreement with the section 151 officer
we're looking to delay those audits
until next year
um what's new for this progress report
is I've included a copy of the audit
plan so what members can also see is
this track progress against each audit
that tells you what orders we're
currently undertaking what progress
remaining where we're at so they gives
you a snapshot for every audit in a plan
where we're at so I thought it might be
useful for members to take a look at
that so you can see where we're at in
terms of living the plan
um
in terms of
audit recommendations we also report to
members that the progress made by
service departments put in addressing
audit recommendations and this is
included at appendix 3. we only have 26
live recommendations at the moment
um it's been difficult to get um a
progress up thanks from officers because
of the ongoing service but we have
attempted where possible to get progress
updates and those laces updates are
included at appendix 3 for your
information
in terms of council fraud work that this
is untaken by the refs and bent in the
benefits section and they report on this
separately
I'm quite happy to take any questions
I'm councilor Sharp
yeah thank you
um
I think the uh the progress of the audit
oh all this is good I would mean and
um
well he seemed to be carried out very
diligently and efficiently
it's what they reveal are concern
concerns me
because there doesn't seem to be a lot
of progress
from the audits in 21 22 and 22 23
.
um
if you look at the progress report
there's an awful lot of naught percents
including one or including several where
the due date is the 30th of September
2023 and we're just over a third of the
way through the council year it just
seems a little bit concerning to me I do
recognize that there's been
on the homes and housing and
homelessness
there's there's no strategy paper as yet
um and there's also been
in terms of the enforcement of the fly
tipping
um not a lot of progress where it is
possible to do enforcement because of
the sickness to a key employee
but this sort of suggests to me that
there's
there's either or both of
a huge stretch to a number of key
employees they're overstretched or that
there's a shortage of bodies
so is there a resource position is it
getting worse and what can we do about
it
in terms of resources something I've
probably defer to Tim on but it could
also be they are making progress but not
providing a response to internal audit I
mean they we are I do chase them for a
response but it's not to say progress is
not being made but it may be a case that
haven't come back to me because of the
ongoing deadlines and also upper
pressures so if likely they are taken
actually and I just haven't got a
response from those those officers to
report back tonight but in terms of
resources I think that's something that
can pass to Lively Tim or Emily to
I think as there is always going to be
an issue of resources the the Staffing
Resources in order to deliver the things
that they promise
um but that's not an excuse not to
deliver on what you say you're going to
do and that's what this report
highlights in certain cases that is the
case
um I do think that it's an area that
perhaps we are not diligent enough and
this isn't a reflection on on my
career's team it's a reflection on the
organization we're not diligent enough
in making sure that those offices that
are named
um are held to account to deliver on
what they have agreed it's not imposed
upon them they have said I'll do this by
this date and then they haven't done it
not to say they should be castigated for
that but they should be held to account
to deliver on it and to have a realistic
timetable and I'll undertake tonight to
make sure following this meeting
um to meet with Mike to go through some
of those where they're the highest risk
because some of them are very low risk
there is an issue of priorities but
those where there's the highest risk and
highest profile and perhaps the longest
delays
um we'll spend some time and effort to
focus on those and I can talk to my CLT
you know my corporate leadership team
colleagues with the relevant director
responsible for those areas which
probably include myself
to make sure that there's a proper plan
in place to address some of these uh
some of the worst examples of delays
responding on recommendations one is the
reason that they're not coming back and
Reporting because they may be
overwhelmed with their daily workload
I wouldn't want to say that no
um that there is a
there are issues with vacant posts
um it's really difficult to recruit good
stuff at the moment
um the there's just not the supply of
people out there to fill vacant posts
they're certainly at the White caliber
which means there's greater emphasis
placed on those staff that we do have
um and greater responsibilities in terms
of the volume of work on them so that's
bound to cause some some pressure
um but speaking as a management rather
than as the section 151 officer
my view is I would always try and help
my managers where they felt that they
needed support
but the important thing is
prioritization
and sometimes uh they need more guidance
on prioritization and whereas they might
deal with something that's in front of
them
member inquiries for example might be
one because they consider those really
important because it's coming from a
member and they'll want to respond
really quickly to that and then these
type of things that perhaps they think
well it's been it's been hanging around
for a few months now another week or so
isn't going to matter and they keep
looking at what they've got in front of
them and I think there's a tendency to
do that when you're when you've got a
lot of work on to do what you think is
the most urgent rather than what's the
most important and you and but there
does come I think it's useful for
documents such as this like an action
plan on recommendations from internal
audits it's also true of the risk
management and risk management registers
another example where it's important to
keep on top of that but easy to to
forget about it from one month to the
next where then you maybe you need a
little recalibration and another
conversation to say look these things
are important if you if we if we don't
address these things we're not going to
learn the lessons from what the audit
threw up and we've got an obligation to
respond
to deliver the things that we said we
would deliver
um so I think that a sort of a reset of
recalibration is useful with
renouncement and around these sort of
things and this is what I'm suggesting
that you do in respect of the most uh
high risk and and old actions
let me ask if uh Emily you have a
comment to make on this
um
so I don't think any of the descriptors
in this table suggest that the actions
haven't been complied with due to a
resourcing issue and there are a few
that are due to software issues or
procurement type issues and I think it's
also important to remember that the
organization is in a state of
transformation going through the one
team service reviews so in some cases I
think it's more of a timing issue in
that we do need to do this piece of work
but there's some kind of um structural
work that needs to be done around
bringing the team together first
um
just in terms of that that piece around
resources I'd Echo a lot of what what
Tim has said and I'd also just report to
to members that as a corporate
leadership team we do look at
performance measures across the
organization we look at indicators such
as vacancy rates
um workloads the the general
um kind of mood of the organization and
I would say that right now we don't have
any major concerns reported to us about
resourcing or officers feeling
overwhelmed in your words councilor
sharp so and please be assured that we
would carefully monitor that and we
would identify that and respond if
needed and again I would just support
what Tim has said that
you know a lot of this is about
accountability so I would expect to see
a much thorough note in this report to
explain why a deadline hasn't been met
or explain why a slippage has been
requested
um and also I think it you know it is a
snapshot in time so some of these I
already know have been moved on just
looking at one at the moment about the
emergency planning and the emergency
volunteers that has now been approved by
the corporate leadership team so
um you know this is a sort of a month
ago you probably had the comments coming
in so some of them have already moved on
okay thank you
[Music]
oh thank you I'm the councilor Mrs
Wilson thank you
thank you chair
I say Tim
Tim
the only thing I would like to say is
that I think if officers don't give this
the due regard and attention that it
deserves we're not only at risk of
um damage to ourselves but we're very
much a reputational risk as well
internal audits
should I say audits in general are here
to protect us as much as to
point us in the right direction if we're
going wrong and I'm actually quite
disappointed at the number of
outstanding responses that they were due
to go to Mike
just wanted to say that and if we could
pick it up the next time that would be
great thank you oh thank you cancer
wasn't one thing I would suggest is for
the next meeting if we have a simplified
list of those issues that are behind
but put in priority order
who's already have if you'll get
7.3.1 we already have a system a traffic
right system almost so if there is
anything important there we should that
should be highlighted and
because we understand that there will be
more more minor issues that are in the
volume area that may be technical
problems but anyway thank you thank you
sort of a councilman I'm not sure who
I'm addressing this to perhaps to Emily
is it not possible in this report for us
for column to suggest which departments
or hasn't responded instead of a date
not completed could we have no response
from the Department or the officers so
that we're not just thinking it's behind
but we're actually knowing the the audit
have not been given the information they
need because that makes us more aware of
the well it seems to me like a
management problem but I would be
grateful to know that
thank you Terry yes um absolutely we can
include some more detail and one of the
things that's crossed my mind as as
we've been talking this evening is that
actually the director responsible for
the area should also be listed uh in the
report because ultimately the
accountability lies with that person so
so yes absolutely I think we can give
you some more detail around you know was
there a response received that suggested
an extension or was just no response
received at all
that would be perfect Emily
thank you Emily
members
um
are there any more questions another
question sorry I have something cancer
shot
I'm sorry
there was something something came to
mind
have you seen an impact
on delivery and responses due to
homework in has that made any impact or
major is my
more difficult in getting responses
I don't think it's made it more
difficult I mean from experience of
working internal audit about 25 years I
think sometimes Performance Management
is seen as an admin tool it's not top
priority so it often gets left the last
minute
um
as as it was already been stated that
yeah I mean we we do Audits and
basically they highlight areas of
control weakness so you know we are
seeing substances regarding angels with
authority we do it to protect the
officers and the council so if you're
not putting in place those control
measures then those weaknesses still
persist so but we're not just making
recommendations
deeply full of fun of it they are
identified
um shortcomings or weaknesses that need
to be addressed but I think sometimes
Performance Management is one of those
things that is often seen as a if you're
like an admin Joy it needs to be done
but it's probably not top of a manager's
list of things to do I mean from
personal experience it's not just a
problem for um brochure I mean I
experience the same issues in chasing
recommendations so it's not it's not
just an issue for rotted I think it's
just the nature of the Beast and that
you know you know budget monitoring
dealing recommendations dealing with
performance indicators dealing your
risks so part of a long list of um admin
tasks that a manager has to undertake
and you know it's a pressure on there
that you know their day-to-day workload
I don't think I don't think working from
homeless it's made it worse
it's not
thank you
all right councilor sharp and then we've
got counselor
I need to clear my voice again uh thank
you Mr chairman
um looking at the risk register and
under equality and diversity
maybe a little bit sensitive issue of
this one but uh is the council confident
that we may not face claims
back in back in the past that Birmingham
city council have faced
um not
um not because I'm an expert on
um equal pay claims but only because
it's at the front of my brain um I have
contacted Nicola Mann who's the HR
Director
yesterday
um
if there's any exposure
um she has already briefed CLT to say
she thinks that there isn't a
significant issue but I am very
conscious that as a section 151 officer
I'm uh I would want to make provision
for any potential risks and
contingencies and weigh those risks and
the fact we're in a level of provision
that I thought was appropriate normally
we put that in reserves we create
earmarked Reserve quantifier in money
terms and then set up a reserve and then
put it away just in case it happens so
that's what I've asked my colleague to
tell me sort of what's the worst case
scenario for for Watford and then weigh
that up after discussion and decide
whether or not it was in adding a
reserve to set aside to provide the
protection in the council from something
happening you don't want to do that to
an end degree because you you'll see
risks everywhere and you'll end up not
having any money because you'll have put
it all away for things that may never
happen but it's a judgment call but
that's one of those things that's on our
radar and I will be picking that up as
part of
um this year's
um finances but in particular looking at
towards next year's budget and the level
of reserves that we've got to play with
next year
right and counselor Stuart Wilson thank
you chairman um following up from the
point that councilor Gadsden made
um I've got some sympathy
um about getting people to fill in
returns and chasing them up for that and
in organizations that I've worked for in
the past to overcome that what we did
was we put those
um returns as part of the annual
reporting cycle on individuals I don't
know whether that's done or whether
that's something that could be done
I think I'll take that that one chair
um it's certainly something that should
form part of the regular one-to-one
conversations that managers have with
their staff at all levels throughout the
organization
um and we do monitor team performance
indicators and personal performance
indicators so if this aspect isn't being
picked up specifically in those
conversations that's something that at
CLT we could suggest to the directors
and and the managers thereafter that
they're having those those conversations
about this kind of performance area in
particular
okay all right thank you announced
Council wouldn't
thank you chairman
um
councilor sharp along with others have
sort of set my my mind ticking
um in terms of coming back to
productivity
um and
I've never quite been comfortable with
the fact that we have some reasonably
absolute productivity measures in place
to measure output by
um I'm absolutely convinced that
pretty well all of our staff because you
know I'm not naive enough to realize
that human nature plays a bit of a part
but let's say all of our staff work very
diligently
um and I believe that there's many
working Way Beyond the Call of Duty but
there is a welfare issue here in terms
of making sure that
responsibly we are aware of of any
issues so
a little alarmed to hear
like we don't really know we gloss over
this productivity homeworking
um whether people are focused on the
organizational aims and objectives
because I think people genuinely will
come in and they will give an honest
what they believe is an honest days work
for an only stage pay and are very
sincere so there is absolutely no
criticism but is it focused in terms of
the organization aims and objectives and
I think it's a real there won't be an
answer tonight but I think it's a real
bit of focus that needs to be given
first of all to have
a more absolute
theoretical view of what we expect
productivity to be because if someone is
doing more than that theoretical we need
to review that standard to see a weather
the standard is right or whether to
achieve that productivity someone is
actually working all the hours God send
and they ought to be given welfare
advice on not working quite so hard
because a lot of people want to exceed
their targets so I think there's a
little bit more refinement that that
needs to go on in terms of productivity
home working
and I think I think it just needs to be
a little bit more work done
um to give us confidence and it's not in
any way reflecting on the diligence of
our our people
um I believe for a relatively small
Workforce uh all the services that we
cover they do an absolutely Splendid job
so it's not you know making any
criticism but I think as managers and
directors we ought to have a much better
handle on productivity so that there is
is a much more uh
clearly understood standards of
expectation of the organizations aims
and objectives and also people's
performance against those standards
thank you chairman thank you Council
um there's one comment I will make when
I was you know get the violin out there
with the Met
we had a manager or a staff meeting with
middle managers like a round table every
month and what was on target was above
average on the average line was green
and what was in the red area that didn't
mean to say we were going to torture the
people who are in the red area we needed
to know what they needed were did they
need training did they need more help
with something so we actually
performance managed that group that way
so what I'd suggest is perhaps a kind of
a report on that issue
if we get that to to the audit committee
uh I don't know if it would be annually
probably uh because here we've got the
data but it's kind of in a big table
it's uh you can't move it around easily
as this in this format and we could do
that and that makes it very transparent
and hopefully would show up any problems
and if anyone is stressed out then that
would
you know would be good for the staff as
well thank you
I'll just add to one thing I mean I
suppose homework has made my life I'm
working my team a bit more difficult
because when everyone's in the office
you could actually walk up to their desk
and and ask them some questions and sit
there until they gave you the answer so
now where you've only got email
exchanges or teams it's a bit more
difficult because they continues to
ignore you if they so wish but when you
could walk into their office and sit at
their desk you know looking into their
eyes say I need some updates now you
know
it sound a bit easier so I think it's
become a bit more difficult but you know
that's that's homeworking as you know
with the face reality
yes I'm sorry Emily
thank you chair I just wanted to make a
few comments um just initially in
response to some of the points that
councilor Wooten made and I do think
this is a broader conversation and there
has been in the pipeline um for some
time a briefing by the head of paid
service on all matters Staffing
um so I'd really like to get that booked
in as soon as possible because I think
it will pick up on some of these these
emerging issues but just by way of some
Assurance about some of our kind of
processes around Performance Management
um every service in the council has a
service plan now with objectives key
performance indicators risks and things
like contracts that are due for Renewal
and that kind of data about kind of
operating the service
that stems from the priorities that have
been set by yourselves as members and
then kind of following on from that
golden thread we have the one new
conversations with all individual staff
members so in old money that's the
appraisal but it's a an opportunity to
have a conversation about
um the aspirations that employee has for
their Career Development
um how they think they've been
performing and then setting those
objectives for the forthcoming year that
fall out of that service plan so it does
feed all the way through and we do
um do that monitoring and and that
Performance Management
thank you thank you uh councilor getzman
sorry Emily can I just ask you the old
um appraisal review I'm not sure what
you called it now how often does that
take place with each member of staff and
then reviewed yeah
so we've
um just passed the deadline for the kind
of annual conversation so so the biggie
if you like
um and then
what we're sort of saying to our
managers is that it's really for them to
manage how frequently those kind of more
formal interactions take place but we
would expect
um every member of staff to have a
contact where you can kind of share
personal issues with your manager on a
monthly basis and it may be done in
different ways so if you've got a very
large team that's perhaps based in the
field it might not be that you can get a
kind of in a room and have a meeting
once a month but there will be other
ways for that manager to engage with
those staff members on that very regular
basis
sorry Emily when you say
um having the discussion about how
things are personally in those
discussions
um do you not then look at the
objectives whether they're achieving
them because once a year isn't enough if
you're waiting for a yearly appraisal to
assess someone's performance then that's
a lot of lost time to make Improvement
or to congratulate and promote so I just
not quite can't quite get around my head
how it's been monitored on their
performance if what I'm hearing is
there's an annual one but
there's not a monthly or a quarterly one
it seems to be a long period
thank you Council yeah I'm sorry that um
my explanation wasn't clear and by by
calling the episode of personal
discussionist meant it was a one-to-one
um opposed to kind of a team meeting
type situation at those individual
one-to-ones things like progress with
objectives would be discussed things
like
um how many hours are you doing are you
working a reasonable number of hours
that kind of thing and all those kind of
welfare checks as well so well-being
conversations would happen
um in those meetings
some people would have those meetings
more frequently so some members of Staff
might say actually I like to interact
with my manager on a fortnightly basis
or if you're new to the organization
obviously you would have more regular
meetings during the onboarding process
so those um kind of checks and balances
and the kind of performance updates are
in there and there'll also be an element
of that in the team meetings as well so
as well as those individual meetings
teams will have will come together talk
through objectives talk through their
performance indicators talk through
risks and then obviously any operational
issues as well
thank you for clarifying that Emily when
when you say
sorry how many hours when the manager is
asking the star how many hours they are
working do I assume that you're not
actually monetary now as your monitoring
outcomes so you know they have set
objectives that they have to me how they
manage the hours is one thing so
when you're obviously I I'm done work
from home so it'd be quite interesting
for me to understand how you monitor
working from home because you cannot
monitor what everyone's doing I know you
can look at how often someone's on the
key on the computer of things so is
management done by objectives and
outcomes that they need to achieve
foreign
management that's based around outputs
and outcomes and I think it's important
to recognize that the business in the
council is so vast we don't all do work
that can be measured by the number of
widgets that are produced for for
example
um so when I was talking about um you
know the numbers of hours worked it was
kind of in reference to the point that
Council of Wootton made about making
sure that nobody is working excessive
hours and then he's not able to take
that that time back or where officers
necessarily have to work outside of kind
of Monday to Friday standard office
hours that they're able to recover that
time elsewhere so it I I suppose that
that kind of conversation comes back to
the well-being piece more than the
productivity piece and and we do operate
on a trust basis with our employees our
employees are empowered to work in the
way that they see fit so you know we
don't do things like counting keystrokes
on a computer to check that people are
active that's not how we operate and as
councilor Whitman pointed out we have a
very dedicated Workforce and actually I
think sometimes the output is more when
somebody is working from home because
you don't have the distractions and
often actually they're more accessible
because they're not stuck in a meeting
all day so I think you know a blended
approach is really important especially
when you've got an empowered Workforce
and a trusting management team
thank you for clarifying that Emily
thank you thank you um if no one I've
got another question
um
I seem to recall there was a proposal
some time ago for an external auditor to
be part of this committee is that still
the case
I believe it is because we were trying
to recruit one an independent person
yeah
it's a question to Tim yes
okay thank you
yes
um we are in the
we have the intention of implementing
the council recommendation that came
from this committee to appoint an
independent person to the committee yes
um I that's been with me and I've not
instigated that in consultation with the
chair of Vice chair thank you I think
I'm
Duty about to do it
um the plan is to start a recruitment
campaign fairly soon I say fairly soon
because Brentwood are doing the same the
Brentwood audience really committee want
an independent person and they approved
it last night has to go to their Council
first but my intention is because I
think it could be quite challenging to
attract people to perform the role if we
do a recruitment campaign for both at
the same time we would end up with one
for each or we could end up with one
that does both they could do both so it
just might increase the scope to to
attract people to perform the role but
there has been a bit of a delay in
actioning that that task but it is still
in hand and I'm expecting to start doing
that as soon as Redwood Council have
approved it then I can and the job
description is identical for both
Brentwood and Watford independent person
so we can have a SEO to manage your
single equipment as long as the chair
the two chairs are happy to to
potentially work together on that if
there's somebody that wants to do both
thank you I mean I should assume that
there will be a a consultancy agreement
with a pretty strong confidentiality
provision
yes there is and um to all intents and
purposes they're Bound by the same rules
as a counselor when they're at Audi
committee okay thank you
I think Tim
um the members of no other questions we
have to uh note the content of of this
report is it noted right and now we can
move on uh to item 8 which is the
exclusion of the press and the public
we've got it in public
do we have to agree that the present
public be excluded to the meeting the
remaining business on the grounds that
exempt information as defined in
paragraph three of part one of schedule
12a of the Local Government Act 1972
would be disclosed
which brings us on to item nine which is
the contract award review